- [Instructor] A question that
some of you might have asked,
or maybe haven't asked is where
do we get our hydrogen from?
Because molecular hydrogen,
if it was just in the air,
it is lighter than the other
things that make up the air,
so it would just float to
the top of the atmosphere.
So how would we get it?
Well, this reaction right over here
is actually one of the
most cost-effective ways
of getting molecular hydrogen,
which you can see right
over here on the right.
What do you do at a very high temperature?
What I would consider a high temperature,
roughly between 700 and
1,000 degrees Celsius,
you get some methane gas
in the presence of water.
And of course,
water at that temperature
is going to be a gas,
we're talking about steam.
And then they will react
to produce carbon monoxide
and molecular hydrogen.
Now something might be
feeling a little off
when I wrote this reaction like this.
So pause this video and
think about what is off here.
And I'll give you a little bit of a hint.
Think about what are we inputting?
What are the atoms and the number of atoms
that we're inputting into the reaction?
And then what are the number
and the types of atoms
that we are outputting?
For example, we have one
carbon that we are inputting
between the methane and the water.
And we have one carbon
that we are getting out
on the other side.
Think about that for the
oxygen and the hydrogens,
and see whether it all makes sense.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
And actually to help us visualize,
instead of just writing it in this form,
I'm also gonna try to visualize
the various molecules.
So this right over here
is a methane molecule.
You have one carbon that is
bonded to four hydrogens.
You can see that up there, CH4, CH4.
Here we have a water molecule.
You have an oxygen that is
bonded to two hydrogens.
And then they react.
You get a carbon monoxide molecule,
or this is how I've visualized it.
So you have a carbon and an oxygen.
And then I draw the molecular hydrogen.
Molecular hydrogen has two
hydrogens bonded to each other.
And that is what I have depicted here.
Now based on the hint I gave you before
I asked you to pause the video,
you will notice that we have
a carbon on the input side,
you have it right there.
And we have one carbon on the output side.
So that seems to obey
conservation of mass.
Now what about for the oxygens?
Well, we have one oxygen between
the methane and the water
that we're inputting into the reaction
and we have it drawn right over here.
And then we have one oxygen
that we are outputting
on the output side of our
reaction right over here.
Now what about the hydrogens?
Well, on the left side of our
reaction, right over here,
we have four hydrogens plus
another two or six hydrogens.
You can also count them here:
one, two, three, four,
five, six hydrogens.
While on the right hand side,
we only have two hydrogens,
and they're in one hydrogen molecules.
So what happen to the
other four hydrogens?
They can't just disappear.
We have to have conservation of mass.
So we need to have another four hydrogens
on the right-hand side of this equation.
Well, how can we have
another four hydrogens?
Well, that's if we have two
more molecules of hydrogen.
So that's one, and then that is two.
So instead of just having one
molecule of molecular hydrogen
that has two hydrogen atoms
in it, we now have three.
So to balance this chemical equation,
all we have to do is say, okay,
we don't just have one, one
molecule of hydrogen here,
we have three molecules of hydrogen.
And what I have just done is
balance the chemical equation.
It's just making sure that we
have a conservation of mass,
that we don't have constituent
atoms on the left-hand side
that somehow disappear
on the right hand side,
or we don't have constituent atoms
that somehow appear on the right hand side
without ever being
input into the reaction.